H control measures voltage this was rich
still crop up dot - buonasera Jong
tae-se monitor mucho by Cinco crew
returns
which filter Border Collies dick cut
contrast a platoon Patras is the little
pair septum modern slavery is happening
all around us it's in our communities
people tend to to perceive it as b-but
sexual exploitation but actually modern
slavery takes on many forms want your
sensation car wash people may be coming
to this country voluntarily they may be
thinking that they're coming for a job
only to find that that job isn't what
they thought it was going to be or that
they're being kept in absolutely
appalling conditions they're not getting
the the salary that they were promised
so good to that a good tip
yes what should we do Josh bulletins and
we operate in Cosmo
the traditional wood don't wanna see a
video video big Atari because of our
husbands as the customer code you can
pick some work out
it's Helmand province sometimes we also
clean than G gamma XI news comes on a
spoon a natural finish that project
knackered which was a persona master she
black the monsoon economist and Barney
I'm told no quantitative
good to see it condemned inattention
Anglia be immeasurably kilograms of
mother country's change mom this proof
llamaron la salut t toasty power 6
maybe locti those people thought yum
tree but did you know plaque was posed
what now Mundi was rusty Limbaugh
pledged multi-party across knowledge
five years was three subjectivist
Noel sluggish llama one is a fraction
and him in any quantity star forced to I
thought Kim was moving this last we've
been investigating your car wash for
some time now and we have clear evidence
that you are breaching the law okay
you you've been keeping people doing
thirteen hour shifts you've got them
living in those little containers
they're in squalid conditions well we've
got footage on it we've got film of it
you're keeping people in conditions of
model and it slavery I am NOT what
they're slaving anybody how about the
work you punched in the stomach in the
office what do you say about that is he
lying as well nothing why should not do
I'm cleaning cars every day I work seven
days a week myself I never forced
anybody or thought of anybody by the
distain here or nobody you can't do that
here
well explain why someone who's so
frightened of you who is proud of him
did he run away no he ran away in the
middle of the night you punch someone in
the stomach I haven't you dock money
from people to discuss bars he worked
for which with no poll I haven't done
that to anybody
let's go look at the accommodation let's
go come come and show as they comment
right goodbye
thank you thank you very much have a
lovely day
I'm swayed nobody I thought
have a lovely day